in a previous video we already talked
about the feudal system how you can have
a king and then you might have some
vassals of the king who give an oath a
fealty to the king in the homage or
homage ceremony might be a duke
and you could keep going down this maybe
you have a count
maybe you have a baron and you could
keep going down this chain of nobility
where
one noble is pledging fealty to the king
is a king's vassal but then they are
lord of another vassal and you keep
going all the way down until you get to
a plot of land where the actual work
might occur and that term
is often referred to as a manner and a
manner just doesn't happen at the bottom
of this pyramid a duke can have a manner
and they can split up the rest of their
duchy and give sections of it to form
counties that could be led by counts but
we're going to focus on this video is
the manner itself because that's where
life in a medieval community actually
takes place and the work on a manner is
done essentially by the lowest rung of
the ladder and that is both free
peasants
and also
by serfs
to get a sense of what a medieval manner
could have looked like here's a picture
and this would have been a particularly
fancy manner right over here this is a
ducal manor so this would have been the
manner of a duke so it could be
something like that right over here and
in this picture you see the manor house
which in this case is the duke's castle
in many medieval communities were the
highest ranking of the nobility right
beneath the king
and so we see these people actually
working the field and we don't know from
looking at them some of them might be
free peasants maybe this gentleman right
over here is a free peasant and this
person right over here is a serf
and the word serf comes from
the latin for service
the same word that eventually gives us
words like servant
and they are someplace in between a free
peasant and a slave they are bonded to
the lord of the manner in this case it
would be a duke but you could go down
this hierarchy you could have a manner
where the lord is a baron or the lord is
a knight or the lord is just someone who
is very wealthy and somehow got access
to a fiefdom so the serfs are bonded to
the land they can't leave without their
permission they are allowed to cultivate
certain tracts of land themselves but
they also have to work for their lord so
they might help plant crops and harvest
crops in the lord's land as well and
they also give a percentage of
everything that they grow or everything
that they do
to the actual lord and if the lord needs
to go into war they might have to be
soldiers in that war you might be
wondering well that sounds pretty bad it
sounds similar to being a slave one of
the key differences is that a serf
actually can accumulate things on their
own they can actually own property now
another term or sometimes a sub
categorization
of serf in the middle ages is the term
villain
and i know what you're thinking you have
heard that term before the villain today
means a bad guy but the term originally
comes from the roman empire when
diocletian the famous emperor who
persecuted christians he also because
they were having trouble getting labor
in
rural villas he began to decree that
certain people had to work in the villas
and so someone who was compelled to work
at a villa was called a villain and so
they were bonded to the land they were a
type of serf
now the fact that villain in english it
means someone who is bad it gives you an
idea how in a lot of languages in a lot
of cultures the notion of being captive
or bonded and poor gets associated with
being bad which seems very contrary to
our modern view of the world now to get
a top-level view of what a manner might
look like
we don't know what type of manner this
is in particular
but the manor house here seems a little
bit more humble than this dukel manor
right over here this could be a maybe a
barren's manor house
now the manor often had a village
this is where the serfs or the free
peasants
might live keep their homes and then you
see the land that is cultivated
collectively by this community not just
the actors that we've just talked about
you might also have a church or a
monastery on that manner
right over here and these strips of land
they might have different crops and the
output of those crops go to different
people the one common factor is the lord
of the manor might get all of the crops
from some of these strips while on the
other strips they get the taxation so
they'll get a certain percentage from
the crops there but all of the work is
done by the serfs and the free peasants
and possibly if there's some if this is
a monastery and there are some monks at
the monastery
now one interesting thing is why you
often see in these manor maps these long
strips of land and our resident
agricultural expert at khan academy
david reinstrum says it's because the
medieval plows once you got going you
didn't want to turn them around you got
some momentum and so people liked to
plant crops in these long strips so the
plows
could just keep going in one direction
and only at the end they just have to
turn it around so you're minimizing the
number of times
that you actually have to turn around to
plow